there are two economic issues that I
want to talk about with you today which
people are often confusing with each
other and Donald Trump actually seems
very very confused about the two on the
one hand you have the federal budget
deficit on the other hand you have the
national trade deficit these are two
different things and historically Donald
Trump has confused the two I don't want
you confusing them because if you do
it's going to be very difficult to have
a productive conversation about either
of them if we're not properly
distinguishing them so as a sort of
refresher the budget deficit is how much
the federal government spends versus how
much it takes in if the government
spends more than it takes in that's a
deficit if the government spends less
than it takes in that's called a surplus
on policy Donald Trump promised that he
was going to slash the budget deficit
because of all the growth and winning
and all of that stuff federal budget
deficit on the other hand you've got the
national trade deficit the national
trade deficit is how much we export
versus how much we import if you export
more you have what's called a trade
surplus if you import more you have
what's called a trade deficit the United
States has had a trade deficit for a
long time I mean since the mid-70s as
measured today the numbers are very very
clear and that trade deficit has grown
pretty significantly over time other
than some reductions towards the
beginning of Barack Obama's presidency
Donald Trump promised to get us a trade
surplus including with China and in fact
part of Donald Trump's reasoning for
doing the tariff program with China was
that he believed it would help to reduce
the trade deficit with them and maybe
even get us closer to a surplus so let's
talk about both of these issues federal
budget deficit national trade deficit
based on new numbers that we now have
which are an absolute and total disaster
based on what Donald Trump promised and
based on what the American right-wing
claims to want first let's talk about
the budget deficit the budget deficit
has grown 77 percent in the first four
months of fiscal year 2019 compared to
appear
a year ago which was already bigger in
2018 than in 2017 a year ago the first
four months had a deficit of a hundred
and seventy six billion dollars in the
first four months of fiscal year 2019
that has grown from 176 billion to 310
billion dollars of deficit why has this
happened I've mentioned this before tax
cuts for the rich combined with spending
increases building on already existing
deficits just makes the deficit bigger
rather than smaller now if you want to
argue with me that hey David the deficit
doesn't matter or the deficit only
sometimes matters depending on why we
are deficit spending I'm actually with
you that's a great discussion to have
it's a discussion that I wish
Republicans were having honestly since
decades ago when they became focused on
the deficit and became deficit hawks but
that's not what Trump thinks and it's
not what Republicans believe they are
hypocrites Trump made promises the
promise was to cut the deficit and the
opposite has happened it is absolutely
exploded now you could also make the
argument that the raw numbers like the
total number of deficit dollars isn't
important because if the country keeps
growing and the economy keeps growing
you have to adjust the deficit to
account for that as a percentage of the
GDP but the GDP adjusted deficits are
still deficits and Trump promised
surplus so the guy's still a hypocrite
and a liar that's the budget deficit
okay let's now go to the trade deficit
we have 2018 trade deficit numbers and
they're the highest ever 891 billion
dollars in merchandise trade deficit and
621 billion dollars in services trade
deficit adjusting that for inflation and
economic growth that is a new record
trade deficit
I was thinking finally Donald Trump can
claim to have a bigger one than Barack
Obama and be telling the truth usually
when he says that it's actually a lie
the trade deficit we knew that
he was terrifying China it wasn't going
to reduce the trade deficit it was
actually going to increase it and it did
we knew that when he was talking about
the renegotiations of NAFTA and other
trade agreements that the entire way
Trump was conceiving of it or more
accurately said misconceiving of it was
not going to reduce the trade deficit it
was going to increase it and that's
exactly what we are seeing so when we
talk about this Pat I'm trying to be
clear and I hope I'm I'm being clear I
hope I'm succeeding it being clear that
there are really important conversations
to have about whether budget deficits
are good or bad or whether it depends
there are conversations to be had about
is it even realistic for the American
economy as structured to have a trade
surplus right now or do we just need to
accept that we're going to have a trade
deficit and that that's okay that's all
reasonable that's not what I'm talking
about here what I'm talking about here
is the completely unrealistic promises
made by Donald Trump which he has failed
to keep and if if Trump had done nothing
these numbers would be a lot better and
I think it just has to do with the fact
that priorities have shifted Republicans
claimed that they were all for lowering
the deficit in the past and it sounds
like now they're more interested in
passing tax cuts they're more interested
in raising military spending so their
priorities have shifted and when it
comes to the the trade deficit I think
Trump prioritized prioritizes looking
strong in alpha and renegotiating trade
deals over lowering the trade deficit if
he changed his priorities maybe these
numbers would shift I would actually
argue that it's not that their
priorities have actually shifted it's
that when they claim their priority is
reducing the deficit it's just not
genuine I think that their priorities
have actually stayed the same and it's
that they lie when they say we
absolutely must reduce the deficit as
far as the public perception of this
you've got the deficit trolls who claim
to actually want to prioritize reducing
the deficit when it's a Democrat in the
White House and then all of a sudden
they don't care when it's a Republican
on the trade deficit I don't think that
if you ask the average not even just
Republican I think if you ask the
average voter are we better off with the
trade deficit or a trade surplus and why
I think three to five percent of
Americans could actually answer that and
so it's a political issue that Trump has
successfully used to convince people he
knows what he's talking about but most
people don't even understand why it
matters and when that's the case when
they don't even have a false notion like
with the federal budget deficit a lot of
voters have a notion I'll be at a false
one about why it matters and why they
think we need to reduce the deficit with
the trade deficit I genuinely think they
have no idea and that's how you end up
with this sort of weaponization of
ignorance and talking points from a
candidate that even himself doesn't
understand what's going on and
unfortunately it works it works on the
American public and trade was one of
these issues that Trump actually in the
pre-election period appealed to his base
within to the Republican base with the
numbers though absolute record huge
deficits trade deficit and federal
budget deficit will there be any
consequences for Trump on that basis as
usual probably not make sure to follow
me on instagram at david pakman a lot of
funny stuff posted there I invite you to
follow me and I'll keep posting funny
stuff today's program brought to you in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listened to on blinka
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically
claimed books to enjoy and our audience
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink is calm slash Pakman if you're
watching on YouTube I'm putting a link
in the video description and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be li NK is t.com /pa k ma n